14 here on a tuesday morning all right
viva las vegas casino the hangover
ocean's 11 that is just a very small
sample of las vegas long film history
now there's a way to celebrate how our
city has been featured on the big screen
bianca holmen is live to show us bianca
get on that bus
i am here you guys i'm on the shuttle
i've got my popcorn and juju's
take a look at this nice shuttle and
this is where you go around the city and
you get to see uh just a few of the 200
spots uh around and movies that are las
vegas has been featured and i'm joined
here by chris ramirez we're here at the
first stop atomic tell us this was
featured in what movie uh well
the hangover of course uh the scene
where the mercedes was crashed um right
out front and there it is yeah and uh
and we've used it in several other
movies vienna the phantoms we've used in
music videos so atomic is just a
mainstay and you were a location manager
for several years in the film industry
you're from las vegas so why was it so
important for you to bring something
like this to our city well i have
sometimes an annoying passion for las
vegas and movies and
people
already the reaction we're seeing people
love it people love the information they
love hearing about movies they didn't
know about they love revisiting movies
that they love um and
las vegas is like the best place you
could do this not only for the amount of
people that want to see this but all of
our locations are on one street in a way
you know a few other streets but we can
really kind of do a straight shot down
the strip to downtown and show you 200
movies that have been filmed here do you
have a favorite i know there's 200 plus
to choose from but is there a favorite
uh from that that you all feature here
on the on the tour uh i mean i love fear
and loathing in las vegas it's just i
mean benicio del toro and johnny depp
are hilarious
i love the hangovers because i worked on
them and they hold a special place to
all las vegas i love a movie called
frank and lola because we produced it
and steve wynn let us film there and a
lot of downtown properties so i love so
many movies here yeah i mean we were
just going through the all the videos
that they have i mean from honey i blew
up the kid we've got uh what else did we
see
original
so many
rain man
rain man then music videos it's endless
you guys we play a bunch of music videos
at the end of the tour we have a whole
section on tv from csi to charlie's
angels episodes all right we've got
someone to talk about and see but we've
got one more stop for you coming up in
the 6 30 half hour again this is
happening right now in our city the
first ever of its kind uh here in las
vegas going to sit back to you guys in
the studio name some more movies that
should be on this tour
did they mention that well ocean's 12
ocean sports
hbo max has a brand new series it's not
a movie so that means there's more of
them it's called finding magic mike okay
it was filmed right here in las vegas
see
it follows 10 regular guys who've lost
their magic oh
and they go through what's being called
magic mike live boot camp
that's right get your mojo back the end
goal being crowned the real magic mike
and winning a cash prize we don't know
what that is we sat down though with uh
host adam rodriguez to talk about the
series
there are so many great surprises in
this show i mean from from watching
these guys turn into completely
different people over the course of the
show to
watch you know some funny some funny
blunders happen and um
you know but but but the show it
delivers so much more than what you
expect i'm excited for people to be
surprised
do you recognize him he was in the cbs
christmas movie sunday night adam
rodriguez
finding magic mike debuts this thursday
on hbo max whoa and you can experience
magic but can we go back to that scene
you can expect and experience magic mike
live here in las vegas at the sahara
that reminds me with show girls filmed
here
yes of course yeah
what a reference
leading las vegas